[Music]
let's go to los angeles california
and drew is there drew how can we help
hi ken and john how are you doing we're
having a blast drew what's going on
so i have a question about a will
about
in 2014
my grandfather died
and
he had a substantial amount of wealth
so
fast forward to today
and the way his design the way his will
was designed was that it was supposed to
be divided up amongst half to take care
of my grandmother and then half was
supposed to go
to my dad and
uh his sisters however
my grandmother did not want to honor my
grandfather as well
so she went to the executor of the well
asked if she had to do it and they went
to a lawyer somehow they changed the
will
and that will is not being honored i was
wondering if
this was legal or if i should be
or if my family should be looking to
take action on this or
what would you suggest well
who so she hired a lawyer
and you said went to the executive
the executor of the will was was nobody
in our family it was a accountant
trusted by my grandfather right
and when she went to the executor
she told him i don't want to honor this
can we change it so they found a lawyer
who
somehow found a way to change it
how much wealth are we talking about
here
i i don't have an exact figure i know
that it's a very substantial amount
substantial like a million bucks
substantially like 100 million bucks
what do you guess
probably north of
510 million okay here's what i'm getting
at
um
a i've never heard of what you've
described
and i spent my career around attorneys i
know a lot of people don't want to honor
a will but that's what a will is for
it's a legal document
so um if you have reason to believe that
something nefarious happened
like somebody
went and changed somebody's will
and is
channeling money elsewhere
then
you can go get an attorney and fight
that that's your legal recourse
um
i'm kind of torn because
i mean that's a declaration of war
against your family right
but also
your grandmother doing that
is also a declaration of war against her
against your family so i mean it's it's
kind of tit for tat yeah i just i'm
curious john i i if the the lawyer can't
do it i mean yeah i've never heard of
him so who what you're not i don't know
the rest of the story and i'm not sure
you know the rest of the story meaning
when the lawyer who was hired by the
executor and grandma
got the will changed did it go before a
judge
so as far as far as i know no however
apparently there was a legal loophole
where
my grandmother did not have to honor
this will
i've never heard a fed yeah we're not
legal
so we can't there's there's very little
we can do other than to say if you want
to challenge this you're going to sue
your grandma i'll go go go get a lawyer
and tell the lawyer the story but you
better have your fax before you start
spending a lot of your money you don't
have you don't have a claim to the suit
because you're not you're not a
beneficiary in the world your dad does
so your dad's gonna have to sue his mom
and to get to the bottom of it that's
right
sorry and then yeah that's no that's
that's the other part of it it's just
kind of disgusting i've watched a lot of
matlock when i was growing up you don't
even he doesn't even know who that is
i'm sure he's too young matt luck yeah
we're not lawyers here's the messy thing
um
my guess is there's a lot more
mess in this family oh i was getting
ready to say to you what do you see in
that we got grandmama and she's going i
don't want my kids to get the money or
grandma's got dementia or an attorney
friend or the accountant reached out and
said hey there's a way we don't have to
give this money away there's a lot below
the surface here a whole bunch um he
thinks thanksgiving dinner's not been
very warm exactly so here's the deal
you're you can sue your grandma and you
can hire an attorney to do a forensics
accounting of what what the will
original will was and where's the assets
and who's got them and why and who tried
to change it is there any criminal
behavior you can do that absolutely oh
sure and thanksgiving is different
forever it's it's already different i
think it already is it already is
probably hadn't been very nice for a
long time that's right that's
unfortunate sorry brother yeah sorry
that we aren't legal experts but i would
talk to pops and he needs to fight if he
wants to fight